why aren't there not more stories of
grown-ups using drugs
the full spectrum of drugs that we're
talking about why isn't there so we
talked offline about joe rogan he's
somebody who started smoking weed later
in life which is an interesting story
like when he's already very successful
and he has a very interesting way of
describing his experience with weed that
it was
like enhancing his productivity it
actually i think he says like it
increases anxiety a little bit in a way
that
was productive like paranoia and not
anxiety
and so that's an interesting story of an
adult talking about the use of weed for
but for productivity purposes
but you don't get those stories very
often why
um i i think fear people are afraid that
they will be uh belittled uh dismissed
all of these things that's a drug addict
or some negative thing but cannabis is
lightweight come on uh you can you can
admit cannabis these days and the fact
that
i don't know when joe started but if he
did start later in life that's cool i
mean you are mature developed um you
have developed some
responsibility skills all of these kind
of things this is a good thing um you
don't want people to
engage in any kind of behaviors
when they're young and in immature that
might put them in harm's way and so we
want people to be um
developed at least uh i mean whether
it's
being in a relationship with a partner
uh or whether it's driving an automobile
all of these things that can be
potentially harmful but
uh extremely beneficial if you are
responsible enough to handle them um you
want people to be mature so that's a
good thing so how are you supposed to
like somebody like me somebody like joe
how are you supposed to understand what
the dangers are what the negative
effects are so you said automobile
relationships
um i think i have uh
a reasonably it's crappy but
reasonable understanding of all the
troubles i can get with in relationships
and what things to avoid same thing with
driving a car i have no idea i'm in the
dark in terms of what
are the things to be careful about what
to avoid with drug u with drug use
when we're talking about the heavy drugs
have you ever drank alcohol yes that's
some russians i know i drink a lot but i
understand that because culturally i
came up
i was taught a lot of like
this is what you don't do and this is
what you do yeah this is when you drink
a lot i mean you you see the effects you
see the there's a lot of negative
examples there's positive examples of
social stimulant there's examples of
great artists using
um alcohol to sort of
i don't know
to help be the catalyst for that magic
moment for you know all of that i don't
i have some examples now especially in
america the same with weed
more and more you're starting to get a
lot of stories on uh
psychedelics of different kinds there's
um
psilocybin where you have
mushrooms or even mdma used sort of
positively there's kind of like
negative
stories from the past about acid about
lsd being used
ultimately for productive like
for productive ends but it destroyed the
person that's kind of how the story goes
it was like a trade-off you take uh
it's like uh what is it robert johnson
sold his soul to the devil to learn
guitar like it's a trade-off you could
take the drug you're gonna create some
good stuff but you have to pay for it
those are the stories that's some
[ __ ] we tell children come on
that's exactly right you're exactly
right these fairy tales these cautionary
tales that we tell people
we have to grow up that's what the book
is about drug use drug use for grown-ups
um you know we tell people
pinocchio
if you lie your nose grow
who believes that who believes that
there are fairy tales but that's exactly
what these stories are they're in the
same vein as those kind of stories as
pinocchio um
you know like you said when you were
learning about alcohol you were told
what to do what not to do so forth the
same can be true with mdma with cocaine
with heroin the same is true because
there are some times when you there are
some potential dangers that you should
avoid
and um i wrote about some of them um
certainly in my work just throughout all
of my writings we i talk about those
kind of things and other people talk
about these things um the problem is
is that we're getting our education
from [ __ ] sources from people who
believe in this kind of pinocchio thing
and it just does not fit with the
evidence and the evidence
we all publish in the scientific
literature all these things that i'm
saying it's there in the literature i
mean at a place like columbia we give
these drugs thousands of doses
every year
do you think
we would be doing this and we do this
with research grants that's public
that's funded by the public taxpayers
dollars do you think we would be allowed
to do this if these drugs were so
dangerous
um it's just nonsense i mean and the
drugs we're talking about
they are all
approved for medical use somewhere in
the world
and the studies you conduct are
basically asking what kinds of questions
so you take uh the full range of drugs
you're talking about uh from from
marijuana to psilocybin to mdma to
cocaine and heroin what is the study
looking at like what the actual
experience with the positive and
negative effects of the experience on
the drug are
in controlled conditions yeah so we did
these kind of experiments with alcohol
nicotine all these drugs in order to
have an empirical database
to tell people
exactly what these drugs do and what
they don't do the conditions under which
the drugs will produce positive effects
the conditions under which the drugs
were more likely to produce negative
effects
all of this information is important for
a society to know uh and and we do know
and and that's why we're collecting the
data uh we're collecting the data it to
help us uh with treatment if someone is
having problems with these data
hopefully we'll understand
more about
how to
help them deal with their problems based
on some of the research that we're doing
you